hey what is up guys I'm cubie HD here
and welcome to my better late than never
review of the Droid turbo
by Motorola so in case you haven't
noticed motorola has been kind of
killing it this year in 2014 they had
one of the most liked wearables of the
whole year they had one of the best
somewhat small phones of the whole year
that one of the best budget phones of
the whole year and they had one of the
best big phones of the whole year and
their latest release here in the Droid
turbo or the Moto Maxx on some other
carriers is actually I think one of
their best experiences yet so
essentially the turbo offers the same
software experience as the Moto X and I
talked a lot about this in the Moto X
review about how Motorola is sticking to
near stock Android to give quick updates
and are just adding a few features on
top to enhance the experience so the
turbo does this too and it's on KitKat
right now but fingers crossed that will
be updated to lollipop very soon and the
other software difference really is that
it has some droid specific widgets some
ringtones of wallpapers but that's
basically it so to best describe this
phone I'm going to give you all the ways
that it's different from the 2014 Moto X
and the first way it's different is the
build quality and materials so right off
the bat what you're looking at here is
the black material called ballistic
nylon and there's actually two choices
and materials ballistic nylon or Kevlar
Kevlar comes in red and only has a 32
gigabyte version looks a lot smoother
but honestly also a little bit slippery
err even though I haven't held one to
determine if that's true but the
ballistic nylon here is much more
textured in fact it's more texture than
any other phone I've held in recent
years is a super 3d woven pattern kind
of like carbon fiber but much thicker
it's actually so thick that sometimes it
catches lint and dust or whatever is in
your pocket around stuff near the camera
and the Motorola logo which I hate but I
still prefer having that a little bit of
texture over something totally smooth on
a phone that's curved like this also
bonus there is no Verizon [ __ ] stamp
anywhere on this phone props to that so
overall the turbo is really well built
like previous droids and it feels really
durable really solid to hold in the hand
and it has some slight curving like I
said near the edges that make it feel
less like a brick and also the edge of
the glass are curved a bit as well so
the corners aren't sharp and the power
and volume buttons are both texture
also fun fact the sim card tray sits
behind the volume keys so you actually
have to remove the volume buttons to
change your SIM card but overall this
thing is built like a tank
and speaking of curved glass that brings
us to number two and that's the display
on the front the Droid turbo is rocking
a 5.2 inch quad HD display so 2560 by
1440 resolution at 565 pixels per inch
and it's an OLED display and it's razor
sharp so basically what I'm saying here
is it rivals the note 4 for one of the
best screens on any phone and we're not
just saying that because of the number
it's great it gets really bright it has
awesome colors very deep blacks because
it's OLED it doesn't color shift nearly
as much as the Nexus 6 when you dim it
all the way and overall it's a beautiful
panel for using the OS web browsing
using apps taking photos videos watching
YouTube whatever actually the turbo is
one of the first phones I got to use the
new YouTube app on which let me watch
the videos in freaking 1440p so it looks
really super crispy now a lot of people
have complaints that quad HD is just too
much on a phone or even unnecessary we
keep hearing that as it could take a hit
on battery life so let's just jump right
into that number three is the battery
now the turbo has a 3900 milliamp hour
battery
3900 milliamp hours that's massive so
you can see it's not exactly a thin
device that's eleven point two
millimeters thick and it's got some
curves you know there's no dimple on the
back anymore it's just a big flat
battery in the back and inside the
Snapdragon 805 and Adreno 420 are more
than capable enough to run the software
smoothly on the quad HD display so this
combination of hardware has a droid
turbo lasting still a long time on
battery now it doesn't last longer than
the best of the 1080p phones out there
as you'd expect despite having a huge
battery but it is pushing extra pixels
and it gives you an awesome media
experience for an extra long time so
five-and-a-half hours of screen on time
is what I get all the time on this one
I'm usually getting about 6 on the
oneplus one which is probably the best
of any 1080p phone so that's really good
for quad HD and it's actually the best
battery life I've gotten out of any quad
HD phone including the note 4 to date so
that's super impressive obviously if you
have a 1080p display on the front it
would last even longer but I think this
is a nice trade-off and it's a pretty
good balancing act and I'm
very impressed once again with the
battery life of a Motorola smartphone
now the last major change for the Droid
turbo versus the Moto X is the new
camera the turbo is rocking an
impressive 21 megapixel camera with dual
LED flash and let me tell you it is a
huge improvement over the Moto X and
it's actually the best camera Motorola
has ever put in a phone not just because
of the number 21 megapixels but it's
actually a really good camera a great
sensor sharpness is on point as you
would expect colors and dynamic range
are decent it's not over sharpened or
over processed like say a Galaxy s5 or
Note 4 photo but the images you get out
of it look pleasing it takes 4k video
and it's a really high quality
relatively noise free image in anything
but the worst lighting so overall when
you take a step back and look at all the
changes between the droid turbo when you
compare with the Moto X pretty much
everything I've mentioned here is an
improvement the camera is better the
battery is bigger the display is sharper
and better-looking I mean everything
seems like it's taken a step forward and
that's why I say the experience of the
Droid turbo is top-notch the biggest
disappointment actually on the turbo for
me was a speaker on the front now it is
a front facing speaker and I love
talking about those and how great they
are but it's only one at the top of the
phone and it's just a small driver on
the left hand side corner it's not a big
old speaker like the grille might imply
it is and it didn't sound very good at
high volumes at all and you lose that on
the stereo audio on the phone is
sideways but even so it adds still take
it over any rear-facing speaker so
that's it it's a droid turbo if you're
on Verizon it's pretty much between this
and the note 4 for best phone you can
spend your money on
so motorola really hit the nail on the
head here and i don't really think you
can go wrong between the two but if
we're placing bets on which one gets
lollipop first i'll put my money on the
motorola thong so there you go guys
that's been it if you enjoyed this quick
video review feel free to hit that
thumbs up button below and also there's
a subscribe button below so you can be
one of the first to see the next video
coming soon thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you